foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is James page here in Madrid at the
ftth council meeting and I'm joined by
anik Martin who is the MD of Basics
unitec
um any thanks for coming and joining us
um lots of different discussions going
on about the importance of delivering
ftth across Europe here this week one of
the things you're particularly
interested is the issue and maybe the
challenge that many people have got in
terms of the skill shortages in the
sector so what's your assessment of of
how short we are on skills and what do
we need to do to address it
well Belgium is a is a very small
country and indeed we miss the skills to
build the networks and to do all the
connections we have to visit all the
houses we have to contact everybody in
in Florence
and yes we we see that we have to
attract people first of all we have to
retain the people or certain people that
we already have in our company we have
to reskill them and because we are
leaving copper and we are leaving coax
for fiber so we need to reskill rebuild
these skills for for many people and
that's a challenge sorry um yeah okay
great well thank you for for explaining
that so um in in in in basis which is a
Basics unitech is a huge company what
are you particularly doing to try and
attract as well as retain well we have
raised our own fiber Academy because we
can see that the schools are not yet
adapted to deliver the right skill sets
so we attract people by promising them
that we will learn them how to do and
what to do which helps of course to
attract young people leaving school and
then then having this Challenge and then
once we have the skills in our company
then we try to attract them with a
career move plan where they can get
higher salaries but also move from from
a simple welder to more complex things
so we guide the people really in their
career in fiber
and obviously you're part of a a huge
company that covers lots of the parts of
the deployment
deployment infrastructure is there any
particular areas that are more difficult
to recruit for than others
mainly welders fiber welders are
difficult in design design Engineers or
designers that's more easy because
people coming out of school with the
skill sets of being ICT related
education they can easily adapt to to
design but it's really the knowledge on
the fiber and then the the real physical
fiber welding that is a problem
and of course we need a lot of trenching
activities because we need to open all
streets and all and get it all houses
there we see a lot of skills coming from
abroad which is good because we don't
have in Belgium the own resources to do
all these trenching works
the numbers have been published I think
yesterday I think in Belgium you're only
at 20 percent penetration of fiber to
the home so we still have a lot to do
with their countries who are at 97 or
even almost done
so we expect somewhere that resources
will move we hope that this mobility in
Europe will happen and that resources
will come for many doing this trenching
work well that's really interesting
because presumably if you're operating
in that European wide Market those
skills then because they are required so
keenly that does that make it much more
expensive if you're having to go out
outside of Belgium of course yeah that
drives prices up if you have yeah it's
resources problems then prices go up
absolutely and if people come from
abroad of course they they have more
costs they need to be housed they need
to be they have vision problems or they
need to be regulated with a lot of
administration around it which cost all
money
sure and um so what about diversity
we've heard a lot in the past about that
there is a diversity issue within this
sector do you think there still is and
is there anything we can particularly do
to to to to make the industry more
diverse well diversity is is a broad
thing but talking about women in the
sector
indeed it is very difficult to get to
get ladies doing this job although it's
perfectly possible so we try to attract
women in our fiber Academy
but what is a Pity is that in the
education already at a younger age
schools do not attract enough
girls in Technical
orientations and that's a Pity that
should change
okay well uh fingers crossed um we do
see some of that change and I'm sure
everything people can see what what
Basics unitec are doing to try and
address that in Belgium thank you for
coming over and talking to us today
nice to meet you
[Music]
[Applause]